♪ ♪
First of all, I want
a hoverboard-- but, like,
one of the good ones,
not one of the ones
that, like,
blows up, obviously.
And then Fallout 4 for PS4.
And then-- oh!-- for my kitchen,
just flatware.
I need some new flatware.
Man, I'm not your bitch.
Get that (bleep) yourself.
♪ ♪
Santa Cam... this has been
a pretty weird year.
You having a problem
with your hoes, too?
Uh, no. I-I was thinking
more like, uh,
ISIS and Russia,
you know, things like that.
That's why, this year,
all I want for Christmas
is world peace.
Now, how the (bleep)
will I fit that into my sleigh?
I-I don't...
Think, (bleep). Think.
♪ ♪
Honestly, I-I just want
a plane ticket home
to see my grandma one last time.
-I... She's... -Yo, get this
(bleep) out of here.
-Get this (bleep) out of here.
-No, no, I... it's just...
no, no, no, are we...
are we gonna go see my nana?
♪ ♪
Next.
Oh, hell no.
Get your big happy ass out
the way you came in.
♪ ♪
Santa got a gift for you.
Oh, wow. Thanks, Santa.
I love you.
Hey, don't make this weird.
I got bootleg DVDs for you, son.
One for five, or three for ten.
How you want to do it?
♪ ♪
I want a racetrack.
I've never had one of those.
You know, with the...
(imitates motor whirring)
-Okay. -And a sled.
Please get me a sled.
And, um, Pokémon cards.
My parents would never
get them for me.
I don't know why.
We had money.
I just... I'm not sure
if they love me or not.
Here, you know what? Take this.
What's this, Santa?
That's the number
to a (bleep) therapist.
Santa ain't got time to unwrap
your childhood (bleep).
-Sorry.
-Get the (bleep) out of here.
I love you.
♪ ♪
-Hey, Santa.
-Hey, white person.
What you want for Christmas?
I want some rock-climbing gear.
-Mm-hmm.
-Uh, also a cordless drill.
And a...
Wait.
Santa, is that weed?
Look, stop changing
the subject, (bleep).
You wanted a bike
or some (bleep), right?
♪ ♪
And also, I'd like
the soundtrack to Frozen.
Nah, nah, that's stupid.
You know what, I'm gonna
get you a sex robot.
Oh, okay.
♪ ♪
This year, I want someone
to keep me warm at night.
-Oh, yeah?
-Someone special.
You know, someone that I can
really connect to.
-Mmm. -That gives me
everything that I need.
-Now you talkin'. -Yeah,
this year, I want a husband.
Oh, hell no.
♪ ♪